This lesson and the following ones are designed to
give you the tools that build designs that scale across
multiple devices. And one of the first challenges with developing
for the mobile web, is the display screen. The typically
small display screen compared to your desktop or laptop
device really forces you to focus on what's critical for
your users, in fact this is what's led to the
recent adoption of the mantra mobile first. Now, mobile first
isn't about designing for the mobile web
before you even think about the desktop experience.
It's really a design philosophy of stripping down
to your core user experience and then layering
additional gravy on top if you have
the appropriate space. For example you might put
your company info links inside a menu rather
then cluttering up your home screen with them.